hello there reject nation namaste
all right hold on we're gonna adjust
some of the focus here look at that
Oh what's you guys we got this thing to
try to make the livestreams better and
on youtube we think it's better to go
bright mm-hmm get washed out got a flat
light damn McHale thanks
kale what's up man 20 bucks McHale mom
mom man I just replied to me on patreon
buddy and oh okay let's see here let's
see here all right
look at that guys much better
there we go much better this is gonna be
the whole livestream I was figuring out
how to tweak this web cam here for you
guys we like to experiment we're not the
kind of channel that goes let's prep
everything and then put it out there no
we want to experiment in front of it
room we want to be partly an
entertainment livestream but also just a
tutorial on how to use this so I
successfully avoided we're gonna not
really look at the chat for a little bit
because who knows we'll see how this
goes
we'll play it by you and but we wanted
to what you might call it do a reaction
to the award winners see who won see how
we feel about all that bidness now I did
hear about a couple already because it's
so hard to avoid yeah yeah and
inevitably you end up catching a little
snippets of speeches and stuff like that
so you can kind of put things together I
went to the gym to do cardio and then
everyone has monitors and of course you
see flashes of like oh [ __ ] well now I
know this one hey I just tried I think
it's like I heard certain things too and
I just tried not to commit anything too
hard yeah instead I watched the movie
Revenge last night oh is it good you
know
John it fails as a musical or comedy but
as a rape revenge thriller it's alright
yeah alright I don't I don't love it
like
everyone else does but you know I
thought there were some pretty cool
sequences okay I think yeah yeah let's
say let's go with this book the winners
here yeah let's do it let's pull up the
winners who thinks Eli Johnson mama oh
man this is except to figure out for the
people that do contribute in the Super
chat how to just pull up the that list
yeah cuz I know there's a way just don't
know how Golden Globes winners here we
go the complete list lists a variety of
New York Times oh man we vote in the
comments that's variety right variety
there their trade mag all right here we
go guys here we go
let's start off Best Motion Picture
Drama both I had a feeling because I saw
no Ramy Malick and I was like oh maybe
he won Best Actor I heard that and I was
like what the [ __ ]
whoa all right all right I know a lot of
people love Bohemian Rhapsody but okay
look guys I'm gonna I'm gonna preface I
have no idea I didn't read any social
media of anyone's reaction yet to
anything all right
no I just know that film Twitter is not
happy about this man I
don't Witter is not excited well if you
guys saw my review for bohemian you'll
know I'm not the biggest fan of that
movie and I got a I saw the movie won't
you be my neighbor recently and I want
to take a different approach this year
to talking about films mm-hmm
first off when I was growing up I loved
awards ceremonies I love watching Golden
Globes I love watching the Oscars as
I've gotten older and then now that
there's like a thousand new films here
it's so much harder to be like even keel
on award ceremonies and what's picked
and whatever because obviously my choice
for this would have been a star is born
yeah but we all have difference of
opinions everything's subjective and I
bet you like shots at serosa Park
because I know this is her favorite
movie of the year Bohemian Rhapsody so
I'm sure she's happy and I'm sure
there's plenty of people who are happy
it's got an a cinema score there are a
lot of more psyched so one side of me
goes I don't agree with this at all the
other side of me goes yeah well this is
a very subjective the film industry
movies I'm very surprised so still even
with that because I'm not gonna sit here
and bash the movie I just don't
I personally I'm not a I'm not a big fan
of the film and I don't think it's on
board with a stars born at all or black
Klansmen or like those opposed to me are
a million times and I'm also surprised
Bryan Singer being the director that
they would give in New York you know
like I didn't even think about that so
right now and I believe he was carefully
omitted from their speech but but yeah
I'm surprised that like if it was a
People's Choice Award I would totally
get it but it yes it's like the
Hollywood Foreign Press and critics and
stuff like that and like I just yeah
very I would love to know the
circumstances that led to that
particular win because it seems like
every other film the category is just
weightier and more successful at what it
does overall and I was sitting there
going why isn't this nominated for
musical comedy why isn't a star is born
why is a green book nominated for comedy
when like clearly what the point of that
movie is cutting to is more dramatic
than it is actually funny to me
to me like these nominations see stars
born is even more of a musical than me
than Bohemian Rhapsody because Bohemian
Rhapsody is like the greatest playing
the Queen tracks over while you're
getting some great reenactments thanks
Derek body wow I can't believe it I'm
actually very surprised as stars born
didn't win I am T I am really light a
star was born it's the one psyched about
especially like Bradley Cooper stepping
up and like wearing ten hats today's
movie and a lot of people really
captivated by stars born so I yeah Wow
varies or Beale Street like and he
huffed there even black panther I would
have understood perhaps more than
because like critics and audiences were
able to agree like everybody loves Black
Panther I love Black Panther if you saw
our top 10 video that's my second
favorite movie of 2018 I will say though
that I think if Black Panther 1 there
would have been some backlash there is a
popular category thing you know yeah
it's a superhero movie - Best Actor in a
motion picture drama rami malek
I feel like Bradley Cooper perhaps fell
victim to the like well he's nominated
for a whole bunch of things yeah I mean
I think Rabi Malik is he does a really
good job as Freddie Mercury mm-hmm
I can I'm so far yeah you're happy good
for you for me Adam I haven't seen two
of those movies I really want to see it
eternities gate where he plays van Gogh
I've heard it I've heard he's terrific
in that Willem Dafoe my personal tailor
and Bradley Q whatever
I was stars born sucker Best Actress in
a Motion Picture Drama like close so
close she beat out Lady Gaga but it
starts more when anything that's pretty
surprised
yeah I was surprised not necess I'm like
it's actually it's kind of cool - GLaDOS
won then just because Oh what's up Oh
crazy game whitey wait when Jim Carrey
was sitting the wrong spot I'm gonna
have to look that up there I did see
some of the interstitial stuff like I
actually thought the hosting gags that I
saw were pretty funny and yeah okay
ASAP Rock LD Fisher is getting hate for
Bohemian Rhapsody why what okay look I'm
gonna make some notes I look up stuff
while we're doing this stream I don't
see Fisher's from LCA theater and what
was the other one Jim Carrey Harry is
sitting in the wrong seat or I will look
that up
okay all right what's next that's motion
picture Musical or Comedy
Green book huh you know we did a review
green book I really like green book that
was a lot of fun yeah IIIi really that
movie touched my heart a lot it's kind
of corny it's kind of cheesy I'm like
whatever yeah and if you don't agree
with it being a comedy because I laughed
a hell of a lot when I was watching
there I thought I did too i dra MIDI
yeah yeah I feel like it's a weird one
too I feel like it wouldn't have won if
it was in drama at all I feel like it
wins by proxy in this category because
it's really like it it's very funny but
the flavor I took away from it is more
the point underneath it which is very
dramatic and so like it is a dramedy and
so I get it but at the same time I'm a
little bit like huh
well no I mean for me I taught all these
movies that I like I've noticed for
almost every one of these categories
I've seen three oh five each category
but I would say that for that category I
mean crazier changes is my favorite one
but I thought the favorite would win
because I people love them at the same
time their green book has a really good
message
it does I don't know if you guys have
heard this racism is wrong I bet people
are super psyched about this either
because I almost feel like crazy
irritations would have been a bolder
choice this green book is like if you're
if you're aware past a certain point the
message is not new like whoo this is
going to reach an effect
are not a lot of people who already
understand this stuff so I feel like the
movie isn't quite as woke as it thinks
it is yeah you know but you know I liked
it a lot it definitely made me feel good
I just think that it's kind of I'm
surprised that's all
yeah it's true you know but hey freakin
Viggo Mortensen got fat you know Best
Actress motion picture Musical or Comedy
I haven't seen everything I like every
different thing I hear about it just
makes it sound fascinating yeah it's a
good thing we're reacting to this so we
can go haven't seen it you're not
necessarily in love with those kind of
period costume dramas you might still
like the favorite because of how kind of
crazy it is because holder is a thanks
buddy Jeff Bridges was high during his
speech oh oh he he he got the Cecil B
deMille Award right oh is he is a thing
that everyone's got to experience once I
think there's one speech I know we're
gonna have to look best television
limited series oh good for Ryan Murphy
yeah honey Versace
I've heard that show is so much better
than how it was advertised really I've
heard it's like so much better
okay the Kaminski method I mean schema
is that the Michael Douglas Alan Arkin
trip yeah Wow I'm terrible with my
honest opinion I know people were pretty
bummed that like berry or the good place
didn't get that especially because Barry
and the Kaminski method are both about
acting but one has a hit man dark comedy
slant and the other one's just about how
does the Golden Globes
they always thank the Hollywood Foreign
Press so I guess it's the whatever that
is I think I assume it's like a bunch of
critics and journalists and stuff
yeah marvelous mrs. Mazal Joe star at
screen junkies constantly talks about
this show
I just can't yeah I just hear great
things all the time guys keep up with
all these shows who watches all these
shows very really I so thirsty is anyone
in this live stream who watches all
these shows
berry-like won me over when i rose an
eyebrow at the concept but hmm and and I
start watching the good place just
recently and that show is top notch -
all right best director at a motion
picture roma is that that's on Netflix
right now right I like its back I saw
Netflix yeah me I have I have a list of
a few movies I'm trying to I'm gonna go
on movie fights later on this month and
I'm trying to just just in case
something's brought up I'm trying to
like catch up on all the 2018 Roma's on
that list which I hear is um an amazing
film on and yeah you know let's just go
over the ones we actually give a [ __ ]
about alright Best Actor in a motion
picture Musical or Comedy
Christian Bale for vice and he thanked
Satan did he yes why to say thanks Satan
for the inspiration to play this role I
saw his speech and his speech was insane
it really it was good but it was crazy
Wow yeah yeah it's it's it's really
where it's a treat wow man if he goes
crazy playing it was like I can wreck
and evening I can wreck a thing than
just one speech oh yeah it wasn't like a
controversial I mean I'm sure Fox News
isn't gonna be psyched about it but I I
mean it's it's pointed definitely and
it's a little like whoa but also he's
having fun okay guy yeah sharp objects
good good whatever Best Screenplay my
picture oh do we got here Romo the
favorite if Beale Street could talk Vice
and green book green book one huh yeah
they heaping the price on green but that
seems like the more it starts the win
I'm like that's literally that I'm
sitting here going good good job this is
a heartwarming tale with a lot of good
work in it guys it's not the best film
ever or the best film on this topic even
recently based off of
Green Book and Bohemian Rhapsody winning
I really felt like they were going for
audience favorites yeah yeah yeah no
till this that's exactly what this felt
like mmm fascinating if my Herschel oli
for green book he is great he's great in
that the man dude Timothy shallow may a
beautiful boy Adam driver and black clay
sursum that's a hard category but my
Hershel ollie did move me a lot but I
was watching that movie yeah I think
I'll give it to him for that yeah my
favorite parts of that movie or the
performances I think all right come on
all right finally stars Warren won
something that's original song shallow
yes that's least shallow the song were
neighbor one cries when she plays it
from the shallows I think so it's like
the main song no it's not the one where
she comes up on stage or Bradley Cooper
oh that's not that one no does anyone
know that name I don't remember shallow
being so heavy belty Sammy loom thanks
doll I used to love watching award shows
total political now it's yawnfest that's
why we just go through the list that's
the only reason we do that I completely
agree with you dear Best Original Score
first man won something
hey that ten hundred million dollars
they threw into that film that did not
make its money back as well were at all
when I'm surprised most funny out of all
all the things a first Mandy the thing I
did not take away was its core yeah I
mean I can't even recall what the music
was in that movie actually now I do
because I remember what we said about it
remembers maybe I remember liking the
music Bella now what it was I'm
surprised I'm actually surprised Black
Panther didn't take that because people
want apeshit over that score oh that's
true man we're hopping around here no
literally watch enough television
picture animated spice murderers
yeah that's great
oh yeah out of all those movies that
would I would say spider-verse for sure
yeah let's say spider-verse maybe
Incredibles to Isle of Dogs I haven't
seen Mirai so Ralph breaks even I mean
the spider-verse did something with
animation that had never been done
before and now I should tell a great
story simultaneously Emily the animation
supports the stories oh yeah that movie
fires on all cylinders because
Incredibles - did like an advanced
version of Incredibles one where it's
like spider-man into the spider verse
that was something mind-blowing only
movie this whole years where I went I'm
going again like right when the movie
was done bought tickets instantaneously
so yeah I would I would say spider is
the only one but genuinely ant like act
its be method you know I just don't
Donna I have no interest in watching
that show you don't want to watch my I
don't I don't
okay so what's so guys catch a sub what
are some of the controversies what who's
richer made in top three best movies of
2018 and why well Sammy we did a top 10
video livestream last week you got to
check out rezoning so much death as to
why so much debt that's a lie so my
number one was a stars born was your
number one Mandy Mandy that's right you
know the movie revenge is kind of like
Mandy except more modern and more sleek
okay yeah I get a very sleek vibe yeah
very sleek a weird like sleek scuzzy
where it's like it looks grimy but it's
sad and I I did say Black Panther and I
figure out my thumb her third pickles no
he's probably gonna fluctuate but ya
know Sammy please catch up please catch
up I think my three were Mandy kam and
upgrade okay good call good call
are there any like actual controversies
from this well looks like the real upset
that's happened
with the golden globes there's got to be
something that's missing I feel like
it's the winners I feel like it's
greenbook in bohemian that's upsetting
people greenbook well I feel like they
at least the movie critics are kind of
annoyed by that and I don't know III I
can't wear some of the back I feel like
yeah they're the both of those are
probably having some kind of a backlash
oh man this award shows are care less
about them what did you guys think about
Andy Samberg and Sandra Oh hosting who
hear this do I've ever heard of that's
crazy
I really liked what I saw the little
snippets weirdly enough like they were
just the right blend like they were just
the right level of like light and silly
and weird and briefly like okay we got
to look up with this Elsie Fisher thing
is Elsie Fisher it's good to have an
Elsi Fisher what were the Bohemian
Rhapsody tweets that she she did okay my
thoughts on this please educated future
if I do something problematic I want to
better myself and grow I was honestly
vaguely aware the director of said film
was bad but had no information as to
Isis or such or what he had done I know
now I'll continue to be proud of Remmy
and the supporting cast because they're
incredible otherwise I will hold back
understand this though there are many
problematic people in Hollywood know
someone who is busy frequently I don't
have a time to keep up
tell me Wow so what did wait what the
[ __ ] did she get like bash for praising
the movie
I'm so happy Romi Malick in Bohemian
Rhapsody won Golden Globes thrilled
tonight is the best night oh come on
chill the [ __ ] out if anyone does a live
stream even attacked her chill the [ __ ]
out god damn you know that's not her
yeah the Golden Globes or some [ __ ] go
after Bryan Singer specifically but well
you know who made a good point to me
about that she's 13 [ __ ] man I can't she
just ridiculous she was just plucked
from obscurity to lead a movie I can't i
don't assume that she's been keeping up
on the movie news this whole time I had
dared I would give her the benefit of
Jesus Christ she is like 14 you know I
would get it if I would even even if she
came out and was like thank God for
Bryan Singer making an amazing film that
really glad they let him do that whole
other cool thing but come on getting
[ __ ] matter over that shit's
ridiculous you see Perry Perry Nemiroff
at Collider brought up a great point to
me about bohemian because as the movie
was being marketed I remember talking
with her about I'm so surprised that all
this marketing they've managed to
completely hide the race right yeah yeah
sweetly hi that pride like you're so
unaware Bryan Singer made this movie you
know like it's not even at the forefront
of anyone's mind and we're ready
you're also not aware of the Dexter
Fletcher flat Fletcher finished it so it
does feel like this weird director list
movie well my point with that is I I was
kind of conflicted about it because of
the fact that Bryan Singer helm the film
and she brought the good point that you
know there's so much more than Bryan
Singer involved in making a movie yeah
like there's there's so many people
involved in this film and then there
were people that had to work together to
continue finishing this film without his
involvement and if so people if people
love it I'm happy for them because
people were that mean I can only imagine
before that cast and crew going [ __ ] we
don't have a director anymore
what's gonna happen to our movies so
let's finish this like a lot of people
came together for that film so as much
as I'm not a fan of Bohemian Rhapsody I
would never want to attack anyone else
except you know because that is that was
a difficult task they had to pull off
yeah and it's also not accept there's an
added layer of like if this was an
auteur piece and this was like his story
and his baby but it's not you know it's
like it's somebody else's real-life tale
so in that way you know it's not his
yeah it's not his creation solely I feel
like these globe these award shows only
really matter in
with the moment that it's happening I
don't think this is a matter to the
people who win this is so
inconsequential and like a year like
this with results like these were is
just kind of at least for my purposes
for the proof of that and I don't think
there's a part like it actually upsets
me that else you figure what upsets me
is not what else you Fisher said would
have sets me is that people attacked her
for it because this is [ __ ] movies
guys it's a movie this is not like the
movie there's one side of me that goes
yeah the right film should be recognized
of course and whatever but then the
other side is come on it's just films
like chill out there's so many more
important things in the world I get
pissed off about yeah then a [ __ ]
movie you know silly silly don't worry
you see that then there's a side here
where it's like well if we hate this why
are we talking about it because want to
talk about just don't give Bryan Singer
any more work and we'll be good yeah you
know it's like he is already working on
that before the thing broke big but yeah
my honest opinion I was like almost the
exact point I was gonna make fact is
people liked it because of the music but
most people didn't like it because it
wasn't a great representation of Freddie
in Queen no that's fair you know that is
nostalgia factor of the movie for sure
mhm
but yeah what's up master bee Master bee
wants to know where you got your shirt I
got it from patron and friend Anissa
liebe unique name huh yes she got me
this shirt else got me a new French
shirt John something else as well we did
not do a good job on on this camera here
no focus and everything oh god this
looks terrible John I'm sorry I blame
you for everything I blame myself
alright guys well that's the list that
we went over like that's the library if
there's anything else that you guys want
to talk about before we log off here
because right like for the Oscars
I hope some more about your idea of
movies because I admit man the star is
more really uh I can read yeah I just
can't imagine I can't I can't believe
that I
I'm surprised - it's quite honestly
especially like with how that movie just
exists in like the style that it is like
it it's so lift in whereas at least for
my experience watching it Bohemian
Rhapsody is like a big medley you know
so well you know I really do think like
this is it's it's so weird what happens
with movie is nowadays in the whole
industry it's so determined by social
media and all this other [ __ ] now of
what they do you know like a trailer
comes out a trailer and then instead of
being confident it's like first they
make a trailer to try to satisfy a
fanbase so they might even change the
trailer to represent something that's
totally not and then they get like
negative feedback on the trailers and
they're like let's reshoot this a couple
months before it comes out so you got
like this department then with award
shows more than ever they they are
they're not just doing their thing
anymore they're really just trying to
satisfy so much like all that [ __ ]
with the popular film category that they
were working on
they're trying this like the dumbest
thing ever and then now like with this
you're like okay whatever these awards
are silly man because this is such an
audience this is such a trying to please
an audience as opposed to yeah and
they're people are gonna say I'm
completely wrong on that and that's the
whole point is that there's so many
different variants and that's that's my
point
there's a billion different opinions
happening all at once and they're trying
to satisfy where's the largest popular
appeal let's go with that yeah the
industry but how do we get the regular
people to watch but how do we satisfy
that like the people who are like movie
heads and stuff like that yeah and it is
hard especially now that there's just so
much more stuff out there I think that's
the other thing is there's so many more
movies and shows and especially for the
Golden Globes that does both yeah
like how at a certain point I feel like
we're gonna lose the ability to properly
survey the Year and award it because
there's just so much stuff to look
through and yeah and so many weird
politics to play about like well maybe
it's because this guy was nominated five
different times because of that and like
you know there's all weird math Sammy
thank you so much my dear you guys ever
want to play the movie game let me know
I love movies so it's hard to find
people who can keep up the movie game
it's the movie game we're talking about
the movie trivia showdown you're talking
about movie fights do you mean that game
we have I have the the Benson
interruption remember the the the yeah
well movie game are you talking about
I I've been on Amy's bring what's the
movie game Sammy will keep a lookout for
your message here
ai ai ai ai ai one of my dream award
shows to put together that I thought
would be cool like starred on the
internet then gret graduates the TV
would be the genre reports I've always
wanted to see that I think that that's
the best way to mean it would be a
forever ceremony but at least it would
be a very concise ceremony yeah and then
what you could do is you could take the
best pictures from every genre and put
them in a final category that gets kind
of chosen or revived yeah yeah yeah and
then you can choose at least you have
the most fair version exactly these
movies are all different yes one's the
best
you know I've always thought that genre
Awards to be the best way to do it
because we got so many movies now that
are probably easier to narrow it down
but like and then you keep everywhere
that's probably the best way to keep as
many people happy as possible so you get
kind of a fair way of voting on this you
know cuz I think I'd be so much fun to
watch to you know even the drone wars I
imagine you get thrown like stuntman
Awards to all these different kind of
things but yeah I think that would be
the best way to do it yeah be fun and I
also think hereditary should have been
nominated us for anything at all
literally anything a sound design a
little respect like I feel like that
movie has that's a movie that audiences
and critics both for better and for
worse have been talking about I mean
people here are saying Saturn Awards do
John rewards and
I've heard about that yeah I guess I'm
saying like there'd be cool them bigger
ones kind of read like retooled it for
something like that
yeah well yeah especially because they
do purport to be like you know we are
deciding for all of Hollywood 2018
what's the best and yeah I feel like it
would behoove you to acknowledge the
variety of cinema by in doing that yeah
at least a little like at least the
Golden Globes divides musical comedy and
drama that's a start but Sammy Liu is
telling us what that movie game is
basically start with an actor actress
and everyone goes around name and movies
they have been in if you want to stump
people or if you get stumped and you can
name another actor or actress in the
category in the issue stop there does
that mean I feel like I'm it isn't this
from a Doug Benson podcast I feel like
I've played this with my with my old
co-worker naming movies a bit in well I
think that yeah yeah yeah it's um we
give us an actor Sammy the way I play
we're like connecting two dot or we
would do we would do six degrees of like
film separation where we'd choose two
actors and try and figure out how to
like link them together by people
they've started with another movies
gotcha
but actually maybe we can just google
the movie and he's a Rob stark Richard
Madden yeah he's uh yeah I know what
else he's been in I lose the game right
there oh man that is a log oh yeah this
game would be a long-ass one yeah that'd
be a fun one play we'll play it on a
live stream one day I mean you just gave
us an idea for a potential live stream
idea man and also guys I watched won't
you be my neighbor the day we did the
top ten live stream of 2018 I was like
you know I gotta see what we were and
I'm so upset because that I did not
watch it beforehand because won't you be
my neighbor is not my favorite movie of
last year but without a doubt the most
important movie I had seen a long time
like I was already like on
like doing a lot of like you know
personal development stuff but then when
I came to that movie that just
solidified a lot of the different
directions in life I was wanting to take
so yeah Vinnie we've been on YouTube for
10 years since the beginning mm-hmm
we started beginning hoop [ __ ] and then
the first six years of our videos got
deleted and so it only looks like four
but don't worry guys we're here I like
that there's random downsizing hate wha
what do you mean somebody just said
downsizing worst movie all right and I
also want to say I did put out a tweet
about it I really do feel happy for
Aquaman like it wasn't one of my
favorite movies of last year but I'm so
thrilled that it's gonna like it's gonna
cross a billion dollars and no matter
what I had issues with with that movie
the level of craftsmanship and
dedication put on screen shows and is
felt so [ __ ] yeah that that movie I'm
really happy that it's about to cross a
billion because it it really deserves it
yeah yeah you see what's on the screen
you're like wow this one must be like
even the other parts that aren't
terrific I'm like this was an
undertaking and I'm glad you're making
your money back because I bet this was
expensive
there's Rosa part right there bow half
bow half wrap a wrap bo burnham is the
best movie of 2018 oh I thought some Tom
makes is mr. Rogers I think he's doing
another one of those what was that Mary
Poppins movie he did say mr. BAE I think
he's doing another thing like that in a
way okay where it's like advertises a
movie about Walt Disney but it's but
he's really the supporting character
it's not really a doctor I think it's
about someone else's life and how
they're affected by their relationship
with all under us mr. Rogers yeah
really I wanted to do a really dark side
of Mister Rogers I want to see a violent
turmoil I want to I want to see the
urban legend isn't there like an urban
legend that he was like a super badass
with like military tats like and
confirmed kill I wouldn't be surprised I
want to make that movie I may be
surprised
badass Rogers the movie man Rambo Rogers
but hey guys we're gonna wrap this up in
a couple minutes but any final questions
let's get this going ladies you uh the
first I thought you said I'm pretty sure
mr. oh yeah guys we are going we are
going to week I heard there's a new TV
extended spot coming out for Monday
night not Monday my college college
college kids college kids are having him
yeah it's coming out tonight yeah why
not we'll stay up to do it we'll stay up
to do it
we're gonna do it what's your advice for
a brand new channel for starters I would
learn how to spell advice properly oh
yeah then you're set from there buddy
hmm for the Batman solo films you want
to be Ben Affleck or someone new I
wanted to be someone new because Ben
Affleck seems [ __ ] depressed yeah and
like as soon as he leaves Batman his
life is gonna feel like 50 pounds
lighter did we see the two new second
Game of Thrones Season eight club you
know if we had it would definitely yeah
we did not see that was way for the
trailer and what movies are you looking
forward to keep a lookout for an
upcoming live stream we're gonna do list
on there and thoughts and you were never
really here that is like the very
realistic version of movies like man on
funny of those movies yeah well it's
more than the vein of taxi driver than
it is like there's that plot like
equalizer man on fire and a Washington
movie badass guy little girls badass guy
a little girl this is a realistic
version and
you know emotionally haunted whatever
that guy was super traumatized in a
realistic but poetic what if that girl
wasn't a young charming sarcastic it
doesn't really be traumatized
that's good move it I did watch the us
trailer did a reaction for on Stardust
and yeah I'll tell you that movie look
some batshit that looks crazy looks Pele
errific I was very much surprised Neil
Reed really hates dad this is like the
fifth downsizing comment I've seen from
you
yeah hopes for glass mm-hmm not high
it's gonna be terrible
yeah blondes or brunettes brunettes
redheads hmm
just to be contrary Charlotte Adams
blind spotting you know there's that's
the thing as it rose the same blind
spotting deserves more recognition a lot
of movies do mm-hmm
a lot of movies is there more reckon
it's really hard actually movies on that
scale it's really hard and yeah Tyrone
Arrakis on Shang loved you master beat
yeah thanks for reacting to our sketch
by the way our sketches they should say
oh yeah we saw that
yeah I appreciate you Samuel ooh thanks
doll do you think Netflix original
movies and shows should be included in
award shows yeah totally I think Golden
Globes yes Oscars the movies because
they don't cover [ __ ] that's all that's
a debatable one you know that dad's for
me that movie fight for me that's a very
debatable one because I don't think that
I feel like it should at least be in the
theaters for like Romo is is something I
understand like if Romo gets an Oscar or
not I get that more than I would if
Mowgli you know the jungle well that's
where I fall in this is
while while I revere the movie-going
theater experience I do feel like at a
certain point if it's a two-hour
narrative story told on film it's a
movie yeah you know nominate it I guess
because you know as so many the thing is
you know that so many of the people who
nominate and vote watched half these
movies on screeners anyway so well I
mean it's conflicting because the movies
that make the most money are generally
not the best movies of the don't get
that much recognition then the movies
that they work their asses off that are
great that don't really make that much
money or you're like stars born is this
crazy thing to me because it's genuinely
an amazing told film that has obviously
had a budget and made a lot of money but
then you know like with with a lot of
see Netflix they produce a lot of
terrible movies they seem like they
produce kind of anything but then they
get like a couple that it's conflicting
because like I think we're all pretty
much sold at the irishman is probably
gonna be a pretty awesome film success
he says he's Irishman and I'm super
excited for that because if there was
one more than Tarantino and Fincher the
filmmaker I follow the most as a kid was
Scorsese and so I'm SuperDuper excited
for that film and I know it's probably
gonna get a limited release and I would
be bummed if didn't get any Oscar
consideration so something like that I'm
bummed about yeah totally totally but
some like that but I'm like I know I
can't just pick and choose
you know like should it or should it not
be able to be considered you know I feel
like Netflix is coming around now to to
that at least for the movies they know
people want to get in the theater
they're kind of showing them now yeah so
that's good I mean if this causes
Netflix and put their movies in the
theaters in order to get to the Oscars I
do support that in fact I might just
agree that the Netflix doesn't count
until they start screening just so I
could have the chance to see me on the
big screen
and hey thanks Scuba Steve for being
here buddy
scooted that yeah punished for season
two most likely gonna watch that guys
yeah Jon Bernthal man all right guys
we're gonna say goodbye at this point we
got a shoot for patreon gonna do it my
hero academia for patreon and res and
then we're gonna do what you might call
it nee what if the buffer only one that
doesn't I don't know we're gonna do some
we gotta shoot some and we got some
stuff to edit as well so I got a busy
day and we want to make sure we're on
top of whatever that Captain Marvel
trailers that drops later so thank you
to all who like attributing the super
chat here's quite a few you guys thank
you my Associated and also can't you
guess you much love John Deere Hart
thing you do this like hard thing was
like sad face alright god much love to
all you see you guys soon